[Music]
we talked about this particular topic
before we brought her back today because
a little bit of uh news came out
caitlyn jenner has spoken out against
trans women competing in women's sports
i agree man interesting that's a tough
position that she's in didn't she get
i remember she got into some [ __ ] cuz
she was like now that i'm a woman
the hardest [ __ ] i got to deal with is
trying to find the right shoes to wear
that's what she said caitlyn jenner man
she she's all over the map with her uh
with her concepts and her ideas what the
[ __ ]
damn dude
here we go controversy over being
allowed to compete and dominate on the
women's team let's bring in caitlyn
jenner former gubernatorial candidate
for the state of california and also an
olympic gold decathlon winner caitlyn
welcome thanks for being here
sandra it is my pleasure this is a tough
subject but it's my pleasure to be here
it really is so take it on for us
knowing that there's gonna be a big
decision tomorrow what should the ncaa
do with this tough decision
well first of all
number one biological boys i've said
from the beginning should not be playing
in women's sports we need to protect
women's sports
obviously this is about leah thomas who
has brought a lot of attention to
to this issue
first of all
i respect
her decision to live her life
authentically 100 percent
and but it also comes with
responsibility and some integrity
uh
i don't know why she's doing this
she's
for two reasons one it's not good for
the trans community i mean we have a lot
of issues in the trans community that
are very difficult and very challenging
we have
a suicide rate that's nine times higher
than the general public
um we
uh but it's also
uh not good
for women's sports
it's unfortunate that this is happening
um i don't know why she's doing it
she knows when she's swimming she's
beating the competition
by two laps
she was born a biological boy
she was raised as a biological boy her
cardiovascular system is bigger her
respiratory system is bigger
her hands are bigger she can swim faster
that's unknown
all of this woke world that we're living
in right now is not working
um i feel sorry for the other athletes
that are out there especially at penn or
anybody she's competing against because
in the woke world you've got to say oh
my gosh this is great and on and on and
on no it's not we need to protect
women's sports and the ncaa
needs to make the right decision
tomorrow and i think that's probably to
stop this right now
rethink it texas yesterday
uh on the 18th went into
no more transgender athletes in the
state of texas you can only compete in
what your original birth certificate
said not if you even have had it changed
but your original birth certificate also
the
um ioc is looking into these issues
again because they've been doing this
for a long time they are located at
issues well caitlin is just a
complicated subject it's complicated
very difficult and as many have written
it's almost an impossible decision to
make yeah she i think she made some
really good points i was uh reading a
very good point i agree with her yeah i
mean i was reading about these two
uh swimmer chicks maybe that's what she
was talking about
but one of them was transitioning from a
guy to girl
and she delayed her hormonal treatment
because she knows that she has
advantages from her biological and so
that would almost be like taking
performance-enhancing drugs and also
like kind of like gaming the whole
system yeah you know yeah that's not
fair you can't do that especially when
it's purposeful and it's like i know
it's hard well it's a tough situation
and a tough topic because like there is
data quantifying all the different
differences between male to female
athletes and how male are have way more
advantages so the fact that
like leah thomas yeah that's her name
yeah the fact that she's beating
collegiate swimmers by two laps yeah
is crazy that's like that's like world
records every single time she competes
in in the context of women uh athletics
so it's
i don't know that i don't know what the
right answer is but
they have to overthink this they're not
taking anything away from them it's not
that you can't compete at all you just
compete in your whatever your biological
gender was is right so it's like to me
i'm like it's they're they're not saying
you can't compete at all so i feel like
that is the fairest way do you feel like
if you
let's say leah thomas right who is uh
identifies as woman but was a biological
boy competes in the let's say men's
sports right and then like let's say
she happens to be really really good and
wins then in the men's sport
it's like all the records are held by a
woman
is that also the same or just by
biological boy i guess low-key i think
that's better than this yeah you know
because at least it's like yo like she
competed at the highest level and
she yeah she's she's athlete like that
that's all that matters you know because
i think the debate is between so like
one thing there
is about uh categorization of gender and
how that fits with something like sports
or a driver's license or whatever
because one is categorizing sex for uh
something that doesn't really have a
cultural like meaning behind it but it's
more like for science basically we just
want to know what your sex is so then
like we can appropriately like deal with
you in medicine or whatever or like we
could categorize you in like sports
where it's like okay just like your
weight class you can identify as you're
thin but maybe like in this category
your heavy weight yeah you know so like
how it's like those two things and how
do they define that i think that's the
battle right now yeah cause it's like
yeah i mean you can identify as a female
and and if if you want to be called a
female and that's your pronoun like with
caitlyn jenner it's like we all say yeah
like you're a she now right fine but
then
when it comes to um
categorizing her in a medical sense
or like in other things that maybe
is just we need something more um
definitive like something that's more
objective where it's like this is what
it is without all the cultural nuances
that categorizes it i think that's what
social norms that come attached with it
yeah because it's like oh well
you know we have to categorize her as a
biological
male that was born but how do you
simplify that too you know because when
you're saying with like weight classes
that's a good point where like the whole
point of sports
is to see uh differences in measurable
wins right so this person left more
weights than that or more baskets were
scored and so even with with weight
classes this is a measurable
equated as much as we could division
and like let's say if someone were to
chop off your foot when they when they
look at the dna they can go okay cool
joe is the dude
just from your foot from your dna they
can tell joe is a dude so measure
by measuring
um you can say this person is in this
weight class in this gender or whatever
and taking out all the cultural and
societal and whatever uh whatever else
that's not part of what's why sports was
created you know and for sports i think
in the competition they're trying to
make an equal opportunity playing ground
for people of the similar caliber right
because they don't want unfair
advantages that's why you don't have a a
[ __ ] featherweight in a heavyweight
in a boxing match because there's just a
unfair physical advantage and especially
in the collegiate level you have d3 d2
d1 so that's another category that like
like complicates the situation even more
and then state like cities and and uh
colleges like it all it really does and
it's also too like title nine like all
this stuff
like that's a whole nother issue that
i'm sure
is really complicates the whole
situation but i think i do have faith
that they'll eventually figure it out
but it's it's still very early after
every single record is broken and held
by a person i honestly believe that's
what they this is exactly what we need
like we need actual like an example to
be like look this is why people have
been saying you can't it's almost like
you can't put a kid in with an adult in
a basketball
like court because like it's just
unfair advantage smash that kid bro it's
on track though there's so many uh
biological guys that are now competing
as women that are just smashing but i
think i think for most people they need
to see this i think a lot of people that
give pushback to these concepts they
probably think yeah all right whatever
like we don't believe you so until
there's more cases of this happening
then that causes all right we tried this
way now we have to go a different path
whatever that ends up being i think i
have faith that it'll happen but they do
need to make some the part that sucks
though is like from the individual level
like let's say you have a daughter
that smashes all elementary sprint
records right junior high sprint records
high schools the top of the state goes
to college and then smash is there then
out of nowhere a biological dude comes
in and smashes you yeah and maybe takes
away your opportunity to go to the
olympics yeah that's the part where it's
like from an individual pers like from a
from a public like issue standpoint i'd
see that like you know it's just
statistics whatever we gotta see where
everything falls but from an individual
it's like man the that part's tough yeah
you know what stuck out to me was the um
caitlyn jenner was saying how like
this makes the trans community look bad
and then so i was like wait what because
i would think if i was a transgender you
know person i'd be like
oh [ __ ] so i could compete in any sports
that i want that i identify with that
i'm accepted in i was like i thought
that everybody would behind the same
thing be behind the same fight right but
then that is a clear
kind of to me it's like wait even within
the community not everyone agrees
that this should be happening so i'm
like well if they don't
they as in like you know their
community can't come to a decision first
then should people be outright going
like as if like this is this is a
standard because i was i was i was under
the belief that this is what transgender
people wanted but now i'm like oh wait
even within them they don't want it yeah
that is interesting to think about like
what does the trans community say about
this topic yeah because i haven't heard
anything from it
maybe they just don't have a outspoken
well i don't know if trans-racial was
the thing uh would biological asians be
allowed to compete in the white math
league
the white mask
that's doping bro you better watch out
because what if they start smashing and
all the white kids it's not fair what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] chain came out of
nowhere dude he wasn't even a threat
last year
he's a dunn now yeah
if trans-racial was a thing do you think
it is a thing dude there's people that
identify like it's happening now it's
[ __ ] crazy but like no one no one
really believes it like you know it's
it's it's just like
because okay remember we did some jk
news where there was a white guy that
identified as a filipino man
and then he would drive around in a
[ __ ] tuck tuck that's cool yeah and
he was a trans racial man who identified
as a filipino woman he just can't yeah
he can't compete in white sports that's
it he just can't do white stuff he has
to do only thai
only thai athletics bro you know only
filipino sports oh yeah filipino
but like no one took himself dancing
yeah
dj
he's not gonna stand a chance
there's that one there's that one white
kid who um
he he's transracial too he wants to be
korean so bad he got the plastic surgery
to be a to look like a k-pop star
and then so like never served the
military and that one maryland
that one white girl that like was saying
that she was black rachel
yeah that was a whole thing too
it's it's it's it's [ __ ] happening
why is it always white people turn into
the other people though because i feel
like if uh trans racial was a really
powerful or a popular thing and a bunch
of like minorities just wanted to become
white so that we would have equal
opportunity and we wouldn't get spat on
i feel like that wouldn't be able to fly
it doesn't work that way i guess huh
that's sad
so
[Music]
you